you know I'm not sure that this need to
be new is in fact anything that's
relevant some people some artists their
breakthrough is newness I suppose when I
began the coalescing of all of these
elements was new but the point is to be
authentic and so I'm not sure we've ever
thought that we should go and do
something new for the sake of being new
that's actually ridiculous and part of a
kind of decadence of a society of an art
that always wants to be different
thinking the difference was anything
better it's not necessarily better the
National Parks was essentially the
modulation of all the elements that go
into our film but it would be unique
insofar as the main character would be
the live cinematography the all the
magnificent parks that we've set aside
in conjunction with a set of 50 or 60
historical figures who like a Russian
novel existed in the foreground in front
of that spectacular backdrop that it was
our great challenge to figure out how to
organize the stories of the 50 or 60 odd
people that we introduced you to knit
their narratives together into something
that made a coherent narrative all the
while having this drama play out in
front of I would argue some of the most
beautiful places on earth
you know I live in New Hampshire we make
maple syrup it takes 40 gallons of sap
to make 1 gallon of maple syrup boil
boil boil evaporate evaporate evaporate
that's pretty much what documentary
filmmaking is for me it's about forty to
one shooting ratio to footage shot to
footage used it varies in different
films on something like the national
parks it's going to probably be a lot
more because you're spending a lot of
time with live cinematography but for
every archival photograph you see we've
looked at a hundred and fifty and shot a
hundred and you know had that
possibility of putting in you know 40
times that much fifty times that much in
any other thing and the cutting room
floor as I suggested before is not
filled with bad scenes
it's just scenes that didn't fit you
remember the movie Amadeus a wonderful
scene where the arrogant Franz Josef
says to Mozart too many notes you know
there's a truth to that you just have to
figure out what's gone and if I showed
you scenes taken out of the film you
think what an idiot he's lost it why
would he leave this out but it would had
a destabilizing effect and what you
serve is a larger a larger whole
well as I described before I was
interested in sort of willingly still
photographs alive to explore them with
an energetic camera I to not hold them
at arm's length to bring them alive to
not only look at them and take them
apart dynamically and put them back
together in good storytelling fashion
but to listen to them and add complex
sound effects to add period music and
first-person voices that would give you
the sense as William Faulkner said once
said that history is not was but it is
that that for maybe a fraction of a
second you might feel that you are not
so much participating but you could feel
what it was like to be there even with
the still photograph when you stand in
there silently
in the presence of the Giant Sequoias
you can't help but recognize that you're
a part of something that is way beyond
whatever it is that you envision this
world might be and all of those complex
things and thousands of other things I
haven't told you about are what now gets
reduced to a shorthand called the Ken
Burns effect essentially Steve Jobs
called me up six or seven years ago I
guess it was now and asked me to come
out to Cupertino California he and some
classically nerdy technicians had been
working on this thing called in which
their working title was the Ken Burns
effect that allowed people who
downloaded photographs to pan or I mean
zoom or pan on them and they had
perfected it and this was November and
every Apple computer from then on would
have that as its basic software starting
that January and they wanted to keep the
name and I said I didn't do commercial
endorsements but we worked it out where
they gives me equipment which I give to
nonprofits and I allowed them to use the
name and so all of a sudden it sort of
seeps in the consciousness and the Ken
Burns effect for anyone who has an Apple
computer is part of the lexicon and it's
one of those classic examples where the
technological tail is wagging the dog of
a much more
complex thing but the spirit Steve's
spirit was exactly right that we don't
want to have a relationship to images
that is just at arm's length that we
want somehow to penetrate the proscenium
as we would say in theatres that get
beyond the artificiality the plasticity
of imagery into some moment that might
have something that we could learn in
which one and one would equal 3 that if
you put this image next to this image
that the combination of the two would be
greater than the two images themselves
it's the metaphor as I'm suggesting oh
during this conversation for life for
art for what we're here for it's what a
scientist will tell you they're after